make her look like a popsicle like a
[__] popsicle what's happening you
bad [__] the church or what's
happening now [__] Tuesday night
tomorrow's Wednesday we figure we take
the [__] day off Sam tripley's here
tonight in the house from punch drunk
[__] Sports and many other podcasts
I'm triple at the church Brian C these
guys got like 18 different [__]
podcasts I don't know how they do it
Brian C's in the 8 Minute Podcast the
10minute podcast he's got a sports
podcast the Brian K man how the [__]
they do it I'm a Hunter I'm a Hunter who
the [__] knows what's up with you flying
Jew everything all right with you all
day you've been all [__] up oh man you
got high fast dude you are high last
night last night I got the highest I've
ever ever ever been on THC what I
blacked out for the last hour I probably
had 800 milligrams in me deep well you
should have seen I should have taken a
picture we had oh my God all the stars
and I don't know what you ate before you
got here I had two candies then I got
got here and I ate two stars by the time
I left here I was so [__] hungry I
had to eat the chocolate bar that was 2
oh that happened to me yeah that's
happened to me40 Mig and then I got so
high with the chocolate bar I had to eat
the [__] peanut butter cookie and
that was another 140 [__] eating the
chocolate Barn during the podcast take
it eat a corner I was [__] I went to
pee at 2: in the morning everything was
purple at that time I took exy I'm 144
in North Garden it was something that I
[__] could I was high as [__] I got
up this when I went to acupuncture she
said something to me at 1:00 she go did
you smoke a lot of Pop before you come
here tonight I go I smoke the usual she
goes how long go I got smoked like 6:00
in the morning 7:30 8:15 that type of
[__] and I got busy she goes man there's
a lot of reefer in you I'm like oh last
night I must have dropped a [__]
th000 Mig oh my God I got [__] up and
I called him a few times this [__]
guy got up got in this car and went for
Yum Yum Donuts at like 11:00 That's How
Strong that's how tough his nails this
[__] Yum Yum Donuts dog I was so I
was so [__] the Hollywood one or over
here right over here one Hollywood Shady
oh no that one in Sant Monica it tastes
funny and [__] like they jerk off like
they whack off the [__] something
something's not right cuz I had yum yum
years ago no no they whack off in the
battle like Brad Pit and Fight Club they
[__] uh over here they got a yum yum
on lanasham but and it's disgusting yeah
I didn't go that one I ate there one
time it was disgusting the Yum Yum is by
the school by on Magnolia on Magnolia
that's a mac daddy across from Taco Bell
yeah next to the hamburger joint is that
hamburger joint good I heard I heard
that hamburger place is pretty good you
know what man I went there it had be 5
years ago me walking around the neighbor
went in there got a hamburger it was
what it was no but I I went I was just I
I ate pretty healthy last night before
that I I only had a little bit to eat
but then around 11:00 I just couldn't
take and I was I wanted to just glazed
donuts but I said glazed and I didn't
even look and he gave me those two the
bars like the Twisted bars oh you killed
both of them yeah I used to love the
half moon dude I used to as a kid I
couldn't stop crushing Half Moon what's
a half moon when it's half uh chocolate
half vanilla frosting all day I like
French crawlers but they always have
frosting on them out here I like just
the plain glazed ones I grew up on
[__] timman the chocolate with the
white balls and then when you took them
out the the sugar fell off and then were
chocolatey as [__] then I think anman
stopped making those I like Dunkin'
Donuts when I was a kid in Jersey apple
and spice it's it's garbage now now
they're garbage cuz it's corporate right
they went corporate they were like
little mom and pop they the fat out they
took the fat out of the [__] dut I
finally went to the one in Santa Monica
and I just got a drink and it just it
wasn't the same why are we making
healthy Donuts you're eating Donuts what
the [__] I know it's Donuts yeah no it's
a I'll tell you what that coffee they
got the high level Brazil I bold or
whatever they have at 711 at Dunkin'
Donuts it's [__] topnotch that sh'll
keep you up that shit'll keep do you
ever eat uh pizza at 7-Eleven you ever
see people go to 7-Eleven they get like
dinner they like like it's like they're
going to a restaurant no he tortures me
every time we go cuz we'll go when I'm
high and he'll be like what you want one
of these pizzas those [__] wings and
those churos they got God those sticks
like you got to hate yourself oh my God
those little Indians they haven't washed
their fingers in 15 years and they
always triy to upsell me oh yeah they
always get [__] around do it three Wings
30 cents I'm get the [__] I want to know
what a [__] 7el makes a day but when
I was in Buffalo the cab driver he lived
here and he goes for five years I ran
Sherman Oaks Koga Park his uncle owns 11
of them and he ran five of
them millions and he said that uh
[__] he would make a ton of loot
there as a manag but he didn't like uh
his wife got divorced who the [__] knows
but I know that that 7-Eleven they
[__] upsell you they got everything
in a year they going to have clothes
they say if you own if you own a
7-Eleven you're a millionaire 1 7-Eleven
that's how much money you make on those
[__] that don't stop you sit
there they don't stop and they sell
everything hot dogs churos the [__]
petrified Pizza that I know you ate I've
never eaten that even their bananas are
different like their bananas even have
like a weird look to them and [__]
they're third world bananas that chicken
salad on [__] wheat bread ain't bad
you e that oh [__] yeah I would never
eat anything with mayonnaise I I the
Italian thing you you've I agree with
that I agree with that the Italian ain't
bad there the Italian sandwich take the
[__] take it home take the lettuce
off the L is always bad put it in the
oven dope it up put some lettuce some
olive oil some vinegar and some [__]
oregano with some crushed red pepper
[__] you would know the difference they
you know why cuz they got real pepperoni
and when you B into the pepperoni you're
like oh my God this I can't take egg
salad if it's wrapped up do you know
what I'm saying egg salad should never
be something sold in a WRA no no no no
egg salad's got to be poured I got to
see it I got to see the hand I want him
to be a bad magician I got to see the
[__] Handcock sucker with egg salad
shrimp when I was a kid dog magician
that's a line right there when I was a
kid there was a place on beran Boulevard
666 it was like
33 666 and that's what we called it Deli
666 it was in a [__] white
neighborhood but they were Japanese
people but they made a [__] shrimp
salad that would make your [__]
[__] curl up on [__] New Jersey
bread that [__] Guinea bread that's
hard fried shrimp or steam shrimp no no
no shrimp salad with the Mayo no fried
no I've never heard of shrimp salad
before this rock shrimp like little
shrimps like big prawns and they cut it
up and they put celery and little pieces
of COA and lettuce a little spicy in
that [__] and they put it in
like a long sub [__] do you see that
picture someone tweeted us of the
Northburg newspaper this morning did you
see that [__] they're calling the mayor
like they they compared him to Hitler
what happened apparently he's a dictator
he's taking like 500 Grand in three
salaries what you know when I sit here
all right I'm a felon we got that out of
the way I'm a felon but the reason why
this PO this podcast is never
politically open like
is because I have no knowledge of
politics but the reason why is because I
do not care yeah because it's more it's
just being a [__] criminal without a
gun that's how smart they are they get
so they're criminals without when I
think of the mayor of my hometown I my
stomach and he's got these people
hypnotized he's like Jim Jones and that
that's it's old it's from last week they
just retweeted again to break my balls
cuz somebody retweeted last week and it
shows him Fidel Castro those guys became
there's a bunch of those guys that the
higher they get they get multiple
jobs so they'll get so he's taking like
three salaries it I saw saw the headline
said three salaries and that's not even
with the illegal Kickbacks he's uh
probably gets like he's probably like
Superintendent at schools he's the mayor
and he's probably uh something of
Transportation yeah dude if you run for
public office you're probably a scumbag
I mean that's just my opinion well you
start off with a great intention I don't
believe that you you start off with a
great intention and you know when you go
up to people if they're sleazy if they
got a lot of teeth and they're always
[__] smiling [__] or people
look in the face there's people that I
bet start off with great intentions and
then they just run in and they're
surrounded with [__] douchebags how
many times you have people here that you
knew from The Comedy Store and all a
sudden one day they became a writer on a
show or something and they got
surrounded by these [__] hipsters or
something yeah so you know you see this
guy one night in L release and you're
like hey and he's like excuse me I got
to go and he shakes your hand happens
all the time happens all the time and
you're like I knew you we used to run
together the time we used to walk the
Pink Dot and share a [__] meatball
sandwich and now you're going to treat
me this way you know they just uh but
what would you do if someone offered you
500,000 if someone offered me 500 Grand
and then said all all you have to do is
pass a couple laws that make my business
make more money I'd probably do it 500
Grand a year is a lot of money you know
there's different ways no and I agree
with you you know the medical companies
you know the the pharmaceutical
companies that's all the way up in the
top that's like that's like a complete
different [__] form of stealing you
know you're taking three PE you know you
come to me and go listen next year they
want Sam tripley wants to squash this
law you know talk to him about it his
300,000 I give Sam 100,000 I keep 200
,000 when the scam goes down i r on Sam
cuz he took the $100,000 It's [__]
amazing like I don't even I don't even
think well let me at least save Sam and
look Sam in the eye go Sam your only one
when I get out of here give me a [__]
job no matter what right you follow me
no no they r on Sam oh yeah that's what
they do dude it's it's really I grew up
in that yeah I grew up in that from the
time I moved to North Bergen downtown
once I started hanging out with carine
Bano who I put a picture on on Facebook
the other day I saw that of and eat at
the thing uh I understood it when I go
walk around with him he he tell me come
to these Spanish people's house and talk
to them in Spanish you know to get votes
and [__] like that and I saw it but they
had great intentions the makco
administration Steve mako's father from
America's Top 10 they his uncle they had
great they had great intentions but then
something happened in my hometown that
destroyed my hometown Forever The
Waterfront all those pictures you see of
New York City taking from [__] North
beron West New York Fort Lee hoken you
know all that that that surrounds that
Waterfront but once they started
building in that Waterfront I mean just
want I tell you this this will freak you
out because till this day it freaks me
out and I called him about three months
ago and we had a great conversation my
eighth grade teacher was the mayor of
wehawken that's like my eighth grade
teacher in North Hollywood being the
mayor of Studios City like it's like
you're the [__] mayor yeah why are
you teaching an eighth grade class and
it wasn't a no-show job he was there
every day and he loved it and he [__]
you know but can you imagine that that's
how creepy my hometown is that the mayor
we hawk until this day the only reason
why I could figure out why the mayor we
Hawkin was a North Bergen teacher is
because of that [__] water from
because he went to jail he ended up
going to jail when I through a teacher
Wally Lindsay ended up going to jail
some on the waterfront building some
scam in fact when we spoke a couple
months ago he told me that they wrote a
script and James Franco was going to
play him well what about uh what's that
City where Baron's from H boken isn't
that like more expensive than New York
City or just as expensive now yeah cuz
everyone's moving there because it was
cheaper but now not Apartments you you
remember the movie American hustler yeah
that that the American Hustle that just
came out little while ago yeah like
that's what you're talking about like
the the guy who plays the mayor that he
he's corrupt only cuz he's trying to
help the community and he ends up going
to jail that's why I didn't like that
movie and it it was you know there was
individually great acting in that movie
but the movie should have been about the
the mayor trying to do well what having
to work with scumbags instead of a bunch
of scumbags trying to F this mayor over
but that's exactly what you're saying
like he he wanted to help the community
but he had to play a little game he had
to play a little ball and he ended up
getting [__] by these dudes and going
to jail you know what I'm saying they
take all the money they rat him out he
goes to the jail but they end up he's
only doing like 10 5 years or something
there's not one mayor in my Hudson in
Hudson County where I'm from that ever
just resigns or stops they all end up in
jail I heard the same thing about like
Illinois Governors like Chicago
Governors like the past three or four of
them yeah they all end up in jail cuz
they just listen you just get too
greedy the word gets out and you start
stealing with three [__] hands
everybody who comes to you hey man I
want to build a Honda dealership over
here but it's a no Zone let me see I do
all right I call my personal week yeah
come on down the problem is this guy
wants 80,000 I want 70 [__] th000 you
know the construct the the handicap or
what is that the guy who draws it the
engineer wants
20 and the architect wants 20 at the end
of the day nobody wants nothing yeah
nobody wants nothing it's just all me
just making up
numbers that's all they do that's how
they rob you well what about these cable
companies like what we're paying for
business internet here
is like is probably five times what I'm
paying but I get I get at home but I get
faster at home and it's because they
just don't have there's no other
competition no no no no no they they
they Zone it out it's the weirdest thing
and this is supposed to be some kind of
like capitalism but they've all like
it's all collusion man it's like the
mafia yeah got that neighborhood we got
this neighborh AT&T over here correct
and AT&T doesn't even have the speed so
yeah those are the two options we have
and then Comcast and Time Warner
combined and the biggest thing they're
saying is cuz they're getting
investigated for Monopoly and the
biggest thing they're saying is oh well
we're on different sides of the country
well yeah Time Warner took the west
coast and Comcast took the east coast
and and that's the you have like maybe
you're lucky if you have three options
fos Verizon and AT&T I can't believe
that flies I cannot believe that people
let that [__] fly dude they're like you
can only get that cable company if you
live there you have to go through them
there's no negotiating or fighting over
prices people need internet too much
people like what you would have to do is
boy caught internet but no one's going
to do that well how do you get your own
internet how do they own the internet
how do they how come I can't just grab
from the sky get on my own [__] well
that's why that net neutrality thing is
really scary but like they I forget who
did it but somebody just made it illegal
or or put it on a way to because what
they were going to do is slow down
certain websites yeah for like for fees
or whatever but they're going to make it
it was going to make it for harder for
harder for an independ
contractor or an artist to their website
was going to take a lot longer to load
up and then all the big corporations
would be fast boom boom boom boom but
the FCC guy was like no we can't have
that it was like the most amazing thing
because everyone thought for sure he was
just going to say goodbye to Net
Neutrality which would have [__] the
internet you know this NSA stuff that's
going on it's it really has [__] just
the internet because what's going on is
like Brazil is making their own internet
wow really which is yeah which means
it's going to be completely detached
from from our internet which is going to
pretty much ruin the internet the point
of the internet was everybody's
connected now because we're spying on
everybody now they're breaking it up so
they're going to have their own internet
and it's just going to it's going to
well do you hear about Samsung what
happened with Samsung like the last
couple days they have these TVs now
where the in the commercials you would
talk to the TV and say on or off or
whatever and they just put out don't
have private conversations in front of
the TVs because the TVs are recording
all the stuff and sending it to a third
party oh my God Samsung actually came
out and said don't have any private
don't have any important conversations
in front of our TVs cuz they're getting
recorded I've been telling you that for
20 [__] years dude this shit's just
it's everything that we saw in the
movies is now happening like I'm writing
with this guy named Ben Ben wolson and
he's like writing he's like and I
couldn't hook up this a the aim Chat
thing so he's like hold on let me take
over your screen and the dude from where
he's at takes over my home screen starts
clicking I'm like what the [__] is this
dude I've never seen that [__] before
have you ever seen where some other dude
way over there crun your [__] screen
I throw him
out that's when I throw you out of the
[__] house how' you do it I don't
want to know get the [__] out sucker and
if my TV gets robbed I'll [__] hit
you in the head with a pipe you
[__] weird ass [__] it's it's it's
uh you know the public isn't really
aware of corruption at any level we all
want to believe that everybody has our
back you know Joe American wakes up in
the morning goes to work 40 hours a week
he gets a pension to take taxes out at
the end of the year he pays a tax or he
finds a bunch of loopholes and he
doesn't pay a tax and we feel protected
every level we lock two doors at night
we shut the windows and that's it that's
it that's not it guys yeah that's not
really it yeah so and and and there's so
many things that we just Bank on you
know we wake up in the morning I can't
even tell you who the mayor of Studio
City is I can't tell you who the mayor
of [__] Hollywood is I don't give a
[__] it's got nothing to do with my
[__] world because you know my world
we trying to move straight ahead I'm
sitting there going what a mayor race in
this town is tight who gives a [__] you
don't even live there what do you give a
[__] if they put a park for little kids
I don't give a [__] pigeons die or
not what everybody's always you know
wants to save the whale [__]
right but it's as a young man I saw so
much of it that wasn't it wasn't
disgusting to me I wasn't turned off by
it I I didn't judge you by it I just saw
the way things worked so when I see some
guy going yeah I'm going to the mayor's
office and talking about this I'm just
giggle I just giggle in my [__] head
because I know that this idiot doesn't
even know you got should open an
envelope did you ever think about
becoming a politician CU I knew you
wanted to be a lawyer and that kind of
leads right into no no no no no no there
was no I when I left North Bergen I I
had done all these little crazy things
but the first time I realized I had to
leave was when these people came up to
me and they're like hey man you've been
getting away with Mur you got to help us
now and I knew that they didn't want me
to put put a suit on they wanted me to
burn crosses and do crazy [__] like that
I just didn't want to do it for the sake
of [__] politics for what it's like
anything else I didn't want to do as a
kid you know we robbed this thing one
time we probably got
$25,000 and these gangsters came up to
me they like well give us half and we'll
protect you what are you talking about
what the [__] are you talking half I'm
not going to give you half I give you a
couple hundred you stick around you have
a b do a couple lines but I ain't giving
you half a [__] nothing right and
that's what it becomes you know these I
never understood the Mafia the mafia
wait a second so wait a second let me
get this straight so I'm going to go out
all week and risk my [__] neck to
make moves and at the end of the week if
I make
$55,000 I got to give you a percentage
of my money but if I want to move up in
the ranks I got to give you the most
money so even though Lee kills 18 guys
and whatever if Lee only shows up at 300
Leah is 300 if I show up and I move Coke
but I tell them I'm a bookie and I show
up and I give them 3,000 a [__] week
every week that's 12,000 a [__] month
I give some [__] schmuck after about
two years it'll make me a ganger will
make me into the mafia I could tell him
I'm a book maker but the whole time I'll
be selling [__] blow do you follow
what the point is here here you are a
solid guy you'll shoot people in the
head they don't judge you by that he's a
solid guy you're a solid guy you shoot
people how many people have some of that
good
trips do me a favor uh cover your ears l
no you [__] on the way home go shoot
TBO you know your buddy the long leged
when you do the podcast yeah go shoot
him end his [__] life how many people
have that they could have that power
that can just look at you and go stop on
the way home and shoot tripley he's got
to go he's a [__] rat he went to
Sirius XM you
know do you ever see the movie uh uh
Iceman coming Iceman coming the doc
where he's like to get into the mob they
just drove around and the guy's like
randomly killed that dude walking the
dog and the guy just walked up behind
him boom got back in his car and drove
off and that's how he got in but those
people were psycho [__] pads yeah see
that that was something that people
never understood like that crew was
completely whacked out the problem with
that crew was they weren't six zombies
they really were six zombies but again
Roy de Mayo made so much money he was
giving away 50,000 a week when somebody
gives you 50,000 a week you're like yeah
and you I'm giving you 50,000 I don't
know what you're giving tripley you
might give tripley 10 and say this is
all that fat [__] only give me 10 you
don't know cuz he don't want to talk to
me he never wants to talk to me right so
you don't know so he kept giving them
money until the Mayo kept saying hey
what the [__] I give you a ton of money
when he going talk to Paul castalano and
finally they call Paul castalano at a
weak moment he goes make him and once
they made the Mayo the mail didn't even
report to like it anyway they didn't
even want him around he made people
nervous at weddings and [__] so they
told him don't even come around he
reported to one guy only because they
were creepy they sat around at this bar
I don't know what the name of the bar
was not the motion Lounge there was
something else this bar and that's where
they PL and they killed people right
next door so if they wanted to kill you
they just invite you to the bar and they
go you hungry yeah they take you inside
a guy would come out they shoot you in
the head they wrap a tow around you then
they'd stab you in the heart so the
heart would stop bleeding then they'd
take you in the tub and they'd hang you
upside down they drain you huh and then
they come back six seven hours later
after they ate lunch and they cut you up
into pieces I swear to [__] God these
people this is not that's not a gangster
cutting people up and putting them in a
[__] tub is not a gangster right
that's insane it's it's Insanity that's
that's just another word for psychopath
yeah that's another word for Charles
Manson yeah okay a gangster is a
psychopath he could kill you but he's
out there robbing he's out there [__]
money he's not these guys and there's
some rules right there's some rules guy
these guys killed over 200 people they
weren't in it for the mafia they were in
it for a license to kill people they
were zomos they were [__] zombies
zomos what are your thoughts on the on
the mob cuz you grew up with it are you
Pro like do you hate
them am I Pro Am I hate them uh no I do
not hate anybody like that I grew up
with a bunch of kids that their parents
were involved or whatever I didn't hate
them I just hated what they represented
in a way like what what people got from
them like I don't like when a guy walks
around like when a guy walks around and
he's angry like why should a guy be
sitting at a table by himself like in
thought you know like and two guys are
stand there like bodyguards what is what
does he do that he's so much better than
us that he could sit there by himself
and deep thought and think well
everybody else is you know like that
type of [__] I always saw for what it
was they're [__] holms that's all
they are they guys cutting [__]
corners trying to make a living and they
probably earn 20,000 a week which in the
[__] Street world that's a ton of
money when I wake up on a Monday morning
and by Friday I put together 15 grand on
the street what does that mean Joey
Tuesday tripley shows up with a [__]
truck full of
TVs and he says Joey I just want 10,000
for the load I go out and make another I
make
20,000 that 20,000 is mine I just made
20 [__] th000 you know what you do
then most guys go home and sleep and do
drugs [__] that you do drugs but you get
up the next morning go out and steal
again yeah and you're stealing every day
you got to remember the more spaghetti
you throw against the wall the more it's
going to stick so if you're a 247
criminal you got your hands in a
thousand things you know we're centrally
located at the haha Cafe that's where we
go to eat breakfast and lunch that's
where we're centrally located but there
is where we do a thousand things so if
somebody comes to us and say dog I got
two pounds of blow I need to move it
Trip's the blow guy trip go [__] get
the blow guy trip will go move the
[__] blow with me and we'll each make
6,000 for the day but every day that we
do that we're risking 10 years of our
[__]
lives that's do you think they're bad
people no no they're quiet boys they
deserve to go to heaven they just they
you know you can look at them from 20
different angles when I was Robin was I
a bad person no I was a weak person
because I had the potential to do
whatever the [__] I want I could be a mi
Brick Mason I could mix cocktails I
could [__] a wire a thing no I chose
to Rob drug dealers easy money would you
say would you say you took the path of
easy easy I even though Robin isn't
necessarily easy but quick money quick
money would you say it's ABS [__]
lutely ABS [__] lutely you're an
American you [__] I'm not offending
nobody here okay you [__] get up in
the morning all right you go to your
front porch and there's somebody from
another [__] country driving a
[__] Lexus or a [__] Mercedes Benz
you got to get up every morning you're
an electrician's helper you get nine
bucks an hour you got to rib down walls
you got to take down old insulation
reput the [__] thing up new
insulation you're breathing that without
a mask they don't give a [__] $9 an hour
is what 360 a week yeah let's say taxes
before T let's say they giving you 12
whatever the [__] they give you at the
end of the week what's $12 $12 now was4
4 [__] 80 480 an tax is 400 that's
1,600 a month you're breathing dead
bodies and [__] like that okay your
cousin comes over to you and says hey
let's take a ride to [__] Hollywood
you know help me sell whatever I give
you 500 at the end of the night how you
going to look at that 500 you're going
to go out to your cousins in about two
weeks and pick up another five or four
then about two more weeks you going pick
up another five or four and then one day
it's going to be raining out you're
going to wake up at 6:00 in the morning
you're R of
mayonnaise your girlfriend missed the
period you get in your car the battery
don't start your buddy picks you up you
get to work it's on the third floor you
got to carry wiring up you look up that
wiring and all of a sudden something
just looks at you and goes hey stupid
you keep carrying this [__] up the
stairs and hanging out with these
[__] Momos for 480 a week you can
hang with your cousin on Friday nights
and make 500 bucks and stay home and
[__] your wife in the ass the rest of
the [__] yeah and it it seems kind of
like the answer to the to politics
essentially I mean it's just it you
could look at it from a normal job
people go to work like the electrician's
job the electricians are probably
hanging out having coffee and just doing
the the small stuff that it it doesn't
take a lot of effort or or like physical
effort the mob was just like oh if the
government's going to take
30% and then more taxes and then they're
going to make millions why don't we just
sell the stuff that they made Le
and make a ton of money when we can yeah
you know it's almost like what happens
with adult film stars dude it's like
everyone goes oh it's the great those
girls could go get a real J I know some
of they have college education it's just
quick money dude it's fast money just do
an adult being Ault film star it's like
okay here's two grand come bone these
eight dudes and quick money you know you
you look at Society you look what they
give you you know what are your options
when you're not college educated even
when you're college educated look at
your fck
okay so what are you going to do if I
you know when I was a kid I had quots
quots I paid $2 a piece from so for 100
for 200 bucks I got 100 quaos I could
sell them for four that made me 200
bucks I don't know if you know this 200
bucks a day five days a week is 1,000
bucks a [__] week that ain't too bad
that ain't too bad I know that out of
the 500 Quaaludes I'm going to sell 450
I'm going to eat 50 of them or give them
away or whatever you know you got to you
got to rock and roll still that's a
great profit for a [__] 20year old if
you're not right these kids that sell
excy at these clubs they don't work they
don't work what the [__] they going to
work for you get up at night you go to a
club and sell X that's what you do quick
money quick
money I do do do I want my daughter to
do it do I want Sam's son to do it do I
want your son to do it no we have to
raise him to be a little stronger than
that mentally I wasn't you know I was
out there I saw it it was I was
surrounded with it I was surrounded with
people who had a scam for Life listen
let's get something
straight 60% of the reason I became a
comic was cuz I wasn't going to get a
[__] day job I've said this on
Thousand time 70% yeah I'm with you I'm
right up I'm telling you right now I
knew there was something about hanging
out in the daytime that gave me a sense
of strength [__] getting around and
rushing around and packing a brown
taking orders I can't do that [__] [__]
you I knew that at 16 I knew I was not
going to have a day job so immediately I
started looking for night options I went
with like either a night Warehouse or a
bartender I would have worked on a night
Warehouse I I did I worked on I started
working at a night Warehouse when I was
17 when I was a senior in high school I
quit High School to work at mzbac Sentry
to load trucks at night cuz I never
cared about Night
Life As Long As I Got High I don't want
to give a [__] about going out and
hanging out with a bunch of people at a
bar people breathing vka breath on me
and [__] stepping on my [__] shoes
and acting like [__] wackos I didn't
I never cared about NTI never I could
care less about all that [__] I went out
I went out but I enjoy myself every time
I go out as a child and even today once
I get to what you [__] people say is
great once I get there I look around and
I ask myself why the [__] am I here yeah
this ain't better than being at home
with a bong in front of me and that's I
I've always been that way so I never
really gave a [__] about being I never
got it I've never been super never
really got it super social I could stay
home and not miss I don't know what the
[__] people are talking about so my n
life could have been a race I would give
it all up to be alone in the
daytime for me peace of mind is what I
do now is be alone in the day time alone
the [__] daytime is my gift I love it
I love being able to have my choice I
still get up early still got I got
nowhere to go unbelievable I got nowhere
to go in the morning I don't know any
comment getting up maybe Whitney
Cummings you and Whitney Cummings get up
at 6 in the morning 6 in the morning you
got to greet that [__] with your
dick hard the flying [__] his ironed
you go to my house the American flag is
ironed I got that [__] starched
up I got a little Chinese dude that
starches that mother [__] up but was it
looked down upon when you were getting
jobs because I can't tell you now how
many people I talk to that I tell what
I'm doing and at least two or three
times a week I have to defend my
decision not to go into work and yeah I
could I could be making more money right
now but the 405 sucks doing it for
myself is pretty awesome not looking at
my boss and seeing them drive off in a
in a Mercedes and coming in two hours
late and leaving an hour before
everybody else yeah dude own your own
[__] I've always said that dude Tommy
from The Comedy Store biggest mistake
that dude did he put 11 years into
something he didn't own dude I'll never
invest that much time in anything I
don't own I need to have a piece of that
[__] that that warrant that amount of
investment of my life and my energy man
you got to own a piece because
eventually you just they'll get rid of
you for somebody cheaper or somebody
think different you got to if you own
your own thing you put your time and
effort in you get the the the enjoy the
fruits of your labor that's my whole op
that's the naughty show that's all my
podcasting that's my whole brand that's
all I care about was like this is what I
want to do and I want to own it and I
like being my own boss and I'm I'm more
successful than some not successful as
others but at least I own my own [__]
you're there you're there you're right
there and you control stay in the pocket
clean and sober now I'm getting to the
point where every time my agent calls I
shriek at the [__] phone he is the
biggest pain in the ass like he started
calling me Friday last Thursday hey they
want you to go do for this movie
tomorrow I go first off that ain't
happening just out of [__] just
because that's how I roll they're going
to do ADR for the next month do not
believe that tomorrow because what if I
was on a plane to Buffalo right there
would be no tomorrow so tell them right
off the bat there ain't no tomorrow I
said tell them I'll call them tomorrow
night at 700 and let them know they
called I called two numbers they never
called me I said [__] him for Friday
Monday night they finally my agent
called like Monday at 1 after I told him
I don't make decisions till 7:00 he
called me I one hey can you go in there
tomorrow at 2:00 I said time to call me
at 7:00 I'll let you know they need to
know now they can't know now cuz if I
get an audition overow the ADR so we're
having a waste of a [__] conversation
this's the waste of a conversation why
are we having this bye click this
[__] calls me an hour later how
about 1:30 I was like hey guy relax so
they sent me contracts to go sign
because the contracts get uh renewed
once a
year you know and I and then he called
again I did it already no no no no they
want you to come down from the
commercial department and the theatrical
they want you to fill up paperwork I
said listen you know how many times I'm
on that side of town never all right
just whatever I'll get there when I get
there yeah but if I'm then they hit me
with the we yeah if we if a road comes
out you won't send me
out let me ask you a question if Brad
pck calls you right now with a roll for
fat Joey for 15 grand a week you're not
going to take it because a contract is
signed before you answer that I'll see
you when I see you if they need the
contract sign sign it yourself cck I
just hung up on he called two I mean you
know you're the best I just don't listen
you call your own shots it's because
we're Way Beyond this anymore we are Way
Beyond this I've been in this town for
18 [__] years I heard all the rush
stories how we need this tomorrow and
now there's never a rush for anything no
everyone's boss is is just trying to get
stuff to make it look good for their
boss hurry up and wait dog I was
listening to somebody I was listening to
Russell Peters on a podcast and he was
saying how Conan said it wasn't he
wasn't right for his show and it was
Pete Holmes podcast and Pete Holmes said
trust me I had a show Conan never said
that Russell Peters wasn't right for for
a show it was his producer making the
the decision it's just crazy how people
just make he I don't why would Peter not
well yeah dude you're dealing with f
these people they have their own agenda
does and all this [__] and it's why
wouldn't Russell Peters the guy who
fills Arenas be right for Conan right
it's ridiculous it's
ridiculous listen everybody I love Conan
but come on man it's Russell Peters
everybody has whatever they
want you know maybe has a different
situation you know maybe they maybe that
producer wanted to hire Russell for
something 5 years early and Russell said
no yeah you never know dude that's how
stupid It is Well we don't like wrestle
pedias Hindus don't do well Hindus don't
do well you never know what excuse he
gives you never know what's going to
come out of that mou they got a new show
on CBS that is a [__] direct ABC
that's just racism from the minute you
watch fresh off the boat yeah oh my God
it's this [__] like if I was Asian
I'd look at it and go what the [__] are
they doing I pa freaked out when they
saw when she saw the commercial who did
my girlfriend who's Mexican she didn't
like it or she thought just cuz she saw
the name fresh off the boat she's like
that's the most racist name oh my God
that is the weirdest and it's a cute
show I'm sure it's great you know the
Asians are at home jumping up and down
they represented last Asian was Margot
Cho who they told her she wasn't Chinese
enough or Korean enough you
know uh I said but when I saw the show
and the name of it I was like what the
[__] is going on you know they'll tell
guys like us with two blue for
television and then you put on uh [__]
and he's uh two and a half yeah he's
cursing [__] chicks saying sexual
innuendos you know what I'm saying I
don't give a [__] anymore that's why
you're right I'm so happy that the
podcast came in the podcast has it took
my mind off worthless [__] that whole
agency world and stuff I'm done with it
listen I love performing that's all I
want to do you want to give me the role
give me the role if not I'm not driving
to war Brothers at 3:30 bro I'm not
going I just want I love doing stand up
the only thing I want to do is can I put
asses in seats and even that you know
it's just like that's all that matters
and then it's just like I just love
doing I love standup everything's to do
more everything's to do better stand up
there was nothing in the world
that that's worse than you having a job
that they pay you well for and this is
what you have to do this is what you
have to do you're stuck doing this it
sucks waking up and hating where you're
going and hating where you're going you
know Eddie Griffin was a crazy comic
crazy dude hung out at The Comedy Store
he had a top two movies top two top 10
movies at the same time dog that's how
CRA and we were in that club with him
hanging out every night and he used to
say some crazy [__] things that over
the years are really settled one of them
was you got to stand up to be a comedian
you ain't supposed to have no job you
know like about having a daytime TV job
like on a TV sitcom he and then when he
did it I go what happened to you he goes
man I got like 19 Brothers reaching out
for me bro you know you
just I always thought I wanted to do TV
when I got here guys I I loved it I
loved it the first time I got a show I
think it was
uh in fact it was a James Coburn but it
wasn't Network I think my first Network
show was a show for NBC about
attorneys and I remember that I left
there going this is cool but I don't
know I don't know if I could do this
every day I don't know if I you know
when you get to those sets in your
circle there's 20 people and three of
them you invite to lunch with you for 10
[__] minutes that's 17 people you
look at and you go I don't want these
[__] people either they're too fake
and it's been like the last two years
every time I do a TV show I get more and
more turned off by it like Maron was
great Brooklyn 99 was great I did the
show with the scolar brothers that I
wanted to [__] hang myself on the set
it was bad the people the director was
like one of those CBS directors from 30
years that had done it all but he was
horrible at this point he was just
working on ego now he had like a white
hair and he had the the everything was
perfect his head was shaved perfect and
he would play Bruce Springstein loud and
I asked the chick what is it with this
[__] Springstein [__]
and she's like oh he's he's personal
Friends of the director he always plays
spring stream when he's getting ready to
shoot I'm like this is [__] cheesier
than about to [__] shoot you
know so that's when I realized I started
liking standup a lot more than that when
I started realizing I love movies but I
don't want to do no movie for 10 days
anymore that's brutal the longest year
was [__] brutal after like October I
was like all right enough enough and we
were there to like
December you know after you go to the
same job every day the same tattoos
that's when I started feeling and listen
I'm very lucky to be in the movie I'm
very fortunate but you learned you
learned that uh when I was a young kid
somebody told me something that always
stuck with me it's better to want to
have sometimes you know I was telling
Leo the austino that was a girl in high
school oh my God Sam Tri first time this
girl walked into freshman Algebra I
looked at her the chunk over her [__]
it was ginormous this chick had a
[__] [__] in High School freshman
year that weighed maybe 58 59 lbs what
and she used to wear clogs it was a
monster and I used to look at that
[__] monkey every day I never said a
word to her she was beautiful she just
had big hips she was a hippie
[__] and uh I would look at her every
day she was hot she had and I would tell
people what do you think and they like
yeah she's hot but she was a she had a
little mustache oh man but you couldn't
see it after people insult her then she
got it fixed but she was she had a
beautiful face I love a fat ass oh my
God and finally like a month before my
mother died I hooked up with had a party
we swap spit I started playing with the
top of her pubic hair like I wasn't even
in her [__] range just the top I felt
like the top oh my God my head almost
blew up then she wouldn't talk to me for
a while and my mom died she showed up
and then we were on and off friends
friends for years and to make a St a
long story short my senior year in high
school we started coming around and once
everybody graduated I caught that [__]
off guard but what pissed me off was
somewhere in like my junior year we're
at a Joe Mar's the bar we hung out with
when Lyla jumped off the roof and you
peed on the dog and I peed on the dog
why you peed on her dog it was her dog
and I was just lay there so I want to
see if it was dead so one day I would
just take my dick out when I was coked
up and I Tred to pee on the dog and I
pee on him a little bits of harble I
would never do that that's why my life
was and what the dog did did it ever
move he just laid there and then Lyla
would tell us Weeks Later somebody keeps
paining on my dog my dog I take him home
he smells like
Budweiser [__] horrible I was a
horrible person horrible hor oh you just
didn't know any better dude you were
just young dog that's we used to make
dumb decisions I was young I had my uh
you know I was angry at the world I
would go in there and I hated lla some
nights you know some nights she would
charge me some nights I go in I only
have 20 bucks I want to buy some blow I
thought she was you know and to give me
drinks all night and give me take a five
off the top and she would charge me I
get pissed off a l l you [__] last
night I came in he didn't charge me for
no drinks so so what happened so you
were hooking up with that girl so I went
in there one night we were all hanging
out having a good time and I said
something to her I said I would like to
take you out she goes that's never going
to happen like what are you talking
about she goes that's never going to
happen that was a mistake that night we
got together oh no that's never going to
happen again between a girl like me and
you that was the luckiest day of your
life luckiest day and I looked at this
[__] like you have no idea what you
just decided I'm going to take you into
deep deep psychological [__] Waters
so you know what I did D I stopped
talking to the [__] we got to an
argument one night about I just stopped
talking to us cut her all completely I
did that for like a [__] year if if I
knew she was going to be somewhere I
would not go there I had her on a
[__] battle rope sometimes you got
shut down I shut that [__] down and she
finally cracked one birthday of mine my
one my birthday of mine she cracked and
came over and then we started talking on
the phone little by little you know and
I never mention anything but I always
wanted I knew I was going to [__] her
and rock her world I just knew I'm going
to [__] this chick to death
[__] I was young I'd maybe [__] one
other chick or
something and finally she G started do
blow we were in high school and that's
how I got that was the [__] weak
point right there what is it about blow
that chicks like to get weird she told
me she started doing blow I was like I
got this [__] so we went to this club
one night not all of us I saw at this
club and she's like you don't call my
house anymore what's the problem you
don't like me no more yeah I like it I
go hold on hold on to this she goes well
you going to promise to call me I'll
call you in fact let's go out the dinner
tomorrow night she goes fine I had her I
go hold on to this blow I gave like
three gram of blow to hold she was my
[__] you know what I'm saying once they
hold your blow the year old lady that's
it's like it's like sons of aniy I gave
him my blow to hold I met him the next
night we went to a restaurant picky
lisimo I got the lobster fraud Diablo
you understand me yeah 159 big pimping
big pimping they gave you the big dish
shaped like a fish Bing
weenie clams and muscle surround the
dish and in the middle they got shrimp
and a [__] lobster tail Just Fish
extravagan super spicy I took it for
that super spicy the whole [__] thing
in the car gave her a couple bumps for
the digest and we started Swap and spit
I took those panties off I started
eating that monkey I I called the time
out I put a little Coke Rock in I'm
monkey at that chick at the union that
night when I got thrown out of there
with the Arab caught me EA
ass putting [__] Coke and monkeys
dude this chick was oh my God I loved
her I was really in love with with then
we talked for like two days went back
and forth i t the story the other day I
don't know why you're making me say it
again I'm not making me say anything it
was a great story no you didn't say it
the other day I've heard it before but
you somebody about this the other day
but you said it was better to to have
have than no no it's better than need
than to have or something no better to
want them to have and it was funny that
I was in love with this girl for four
[__] years in love with it like I was
infatuated I go home at night and throw
black sabbaton to real to figure out how
to get this [__] off my mind I play
sabotage backwards and [__] megamom
Mania oh [__] I was in love with this
[__] but I knew I wanted to eat her
[__] like I knew something was going to
happen and here I had her in the car
eating her monkey were you an ass eater
Joey not at that age no at that age I
wouldn't even I was eating ass in about
85 no I wasn't eating your ass way back
in the day son I started eating ass like
an 88 89 my cocaine days yeah dude
that's when you got to eat ass cuz your
dick don't work yeah you got to eat that
ass yeah he has and listen it's your
podcast I'd never tell you anything but
the the story you were telling before
the show about uh drinking uh coffee
late night oh please I was loving it it
was just like you did so much cocaine
that you would drink coffee it don't
work I told people for years coffee
don't work on me these people who drink
coffee oh my God I don't know what the
[__] you're talking about 10 years ago I
shot this movie called The
mesos and I and I snow the coke all
night Friday night Thursday night and
that was Saturday we were shooting in
Pasadena and I remember the guy goes
drink two Red Bulls I drank two red
bulls and fell right to sleep right
after I F drank red and when I go back
to a hotel room after I do comedy
whether it's Thursday Friday or Saturday
night I drink a cup of coffee at night
like like we're talking like 12:30 12:30
I smoke a joint I
decompress I take a hit off the east
cigarette I make a few notes about my
set i f make a few notes about tomorrow
go 9 deep in the email pretty much once
I pretty much once that cup of coffee is
finished 15 minutes later I go to bed
unbelievable and sometimes it affects me
in my dreams like while I'm sleeping
I'll pop up like a [__]
Momo but uh no does I had a fighting
dream last night I literally a straight
up fighting dream and my girlfriend had
to [__] cuz I who you fight who will
you fight I don't even can't even
remember I know I was straight up
fighting she's like whoa whoa whoa you
almost hit me dude I'm I've been allow
fight mode lately dude who you want to
fight I don't I might be do you know who
Jason Ellis is have you ever heard Jason
Ellis I might be I don't know if I'm I
got to find out tomorrow if I'm doing
his Ellis Mania in Vegas in a week and a
half where I'm supposed to do fight for
one minute and a box for one minute and
I haven't heard because he's like I want
you to dress up I'm like I ain't wearing
costumes dog I love you to death but I
ain't wearing costumes but he's I've
always want to do the walkin to the ring
dude that's I've always dreamed of
rocking a little run the jewels man I
want to run the jewels I want it's
called close your eyes and count the
[__] it's the song I want to walk out
and I want to box for one minute against
just a bunch of [__] 5 foot4 Mexicans
I
said and then you do comedy no no comedy
just straight boxing it's a night of he
dude this guy Jason Ellis you should
have him on your podcast you guys would
[__] love each other dude he just
he's going to fight 10 dudes a new round
each round he fights another guy he's
just crazy czy he's [__] crazy how
many minutes each round I I think it's I
I dude it's got to be two or three I'm
going one minute and I'm just GNA be and
he's doing 10 guys yeah he's crazy Alis
Mania yeah who are the 10 guys anybody
random no dude there were some real
dudes man one is my boy kid cop who was
on my TV show back in the day a couple
other mix marshal arts guys and straight
boxing he he wants to fight CM Punk in
the US UFC this guy cuz he is a legit
fighter I mean like he's been training
it's got to be eight nine years now I've
known forever he's taking Jiu-Jitsu Tai
boxing he's a good guy man he's this
crazy Australian dude you guys will get
along great he used to party [__]
hard dude back in the day C all that
[__] you should go for a round Joey
fight a little Mexican dude are you
doing Jiu-Jitsu yo yeah I've been doing
it how's it going I love it I love I'm
going tomorrow 11 o' I've been taking
tie box I can't get there enough but I
decided I got to cuz I'm I'm ding I
don't have a 9 to5 job dog I have a a
[__] 247 job that's nobody
understands nobody everyone's like oh
you don't have a day job I'm like I dude
I have a day and night and [__] way
in the even you have an hour I call it
whenever I have an hour whenever I catch
myself I'm going I could be doing
something yeah that I call that my
Whitney Cummings rule I've laid in my
bed going oh Whitney Cummings wouldn't
be laying right now I got to go out
there and [__] write something I
wrote down three TV projects yesterday
come on yeah yesterday I met with one
writer for this one idea we're doing met
with another writer for another idea do
then I had to write this pitch I got
tomorrow for this other internet series
thingy that I I'm I'm kind of excited
about but it's like dude that's all I do
that's why you got the new hair do yeah
I got the new hair I just liked it man I
just chopped it looks tremendous thank
you you're very nice dog looks
completely different at the Frankie
Valley I'm trying to drop a little
weight man I'm getting it all in
here I got the tits and gut I got the
gun Rock I already got so darkg I had to
go do ADR for a movie today that I must
have done this movie like a year ago
Jesus
Christ every time you do ADR you gotta
face a man in the mirror you're like
Jesus what has become of me cuz I don't
look at myself in the mirror I don't I
just move as I go I just put gel in my
ha and do it and sometimes it works but
when you have to look at yourself for
long periods of time that's scary do
you're like oh [__] I thought I look
good in that
shirt pictures are the worst ah no this
is a movie oh yeah have a video I'm
sitting there watching this going why
don't am I watching this [__] and I had
to Aid y like four [__] scenes and it
was like I got fatter in every [__]
scene oh man it really is amazing guys
what the and you sit there and go that's
it and they showed a picture of me with
shorts I'm like that's it stick of
forkid that's it I'm never wearing
shorts in [__] public again what was
I thinking I'm like I feel like that fat
chick that you see Walmart with Sy Lloyd
and [__] hanging out a tampon string and
[__] you're like why is she wearing
shorts there was a lady in Hollywood on
Salon while I used to live that would
always wear Britney Spear shirts with a
gut sticking out saw that yesterday dude
this chick just straight to go up to him
and say to them can I talk to you in
private for a second why do you have
that shirt on you know how bad you look
do you have any [__] idea and I'm not
telling you that this should be an
[__] I'm trying to help you out
because people are driving right now go
look at that dumb [__] and if not
they're taking pictures of you and
putting it all over their Twitter
they're Instagram they all over
Instagram put a nice [__] shirt on
you not [__] Britney Spears this
ain't [__] this ain't [__] Vegas
[__] my uh my buddy just passed
away had to go back to Vegas for his
funeral he's really cool cat uh just was
in a lot of pain I think he had he had a
drinking problem you know not to be
disrespectful man but dude show up dudes
are at the funeral in jean shorts man
and [__] like Tap Out shirts and I'm
like dude you don't show up to dude I I
might be old school but there's three
times you [__] dress up job interview
funerals weddings she yeah Court fourth
one is Court you ever go to court
everyone's in [__] foooo and [__] no
you got to go you got to go Gotta Go
dress I got out dude I was I was like I
am 13 and three in traffic court most of
it it's because boom I I wear a nice
little suit and I cross-examine police
officers and [__] I've got off dude I I
dude I was trying to make a move on this
chick we were in Sunset and the traffic
wasn't going so I'm I'm going to make a
move on this girl I undo my seat belt I
go in the kisser uplock Captain [__]
blocker with his with his uh uh just
with a like a light his flashlight walks
up to the car that's how slow traffic is
hey pull over I'm rri you a ticket for 9
I'm like we're not moving it's like
doesn't matter so I go to the court and
I'll yell motions I'll try to get
motions to miss motion for continuance
motion for and they're like deny deny
deny deny because I'll just listen to
the guys who are dumb enough to bring a
lawyer to traffic court you don't need a
lawyer for traffic court you don't it's
either the guys show up or not or you
have a case and you can argue with
yourself so uh I go there motion motion
Mo nothing so she goes tell us what
happen I start tell I start
cross-examining the cop and I'm zinging
this dude man I'm and you hear the crowd
going I'm what's going on he's he's got
and the judge is like okay enough just
tell me your point and I go we're in the
slow trap the it's not moving it's dead
Sunset traffic nobody's moving I'm with
this chick first date I take my SE I go
make a move I'm only trying to make a
move we're not moving he walks up to it
she asks him is that is that true he
goes I don't know what's going on in the
car she goes she starts quoting
Shakespeare and love and she's like case
dismissed not guilty cases miss the
whole Court just explodes dude someone
finally beat these cops man and I'm
walking out people are high-fiving me as
I walk out of the Court dude I [__]
cross-exam this dude and one look the sh
for you Lisa at you high again [__]
suuck I am it's a good feeling and [__]
people up don't you I I'm win dude but
now they're telling the cops always show
up cuz they need that cash so they're
always showing up now if you have a good
attorney it's good to to have him on
traffic traffic yeah when I lived in
Jersey I had a [__] monster dog he
was a psychological monster he would
just play with your head and [__] Jesus
even if the judge even if the cop showed
up he still [__] the cop he would keep
you
outside he would keep you outside he
wouldn't say you were attorney or
nothing he would sit in the courtroom
wait for him to call Lisa at Lis at one
more time Lisa at he would wait for the
cop to leave and [__] and then he would
go your attorney Lis was here the whole
time he didn't hear you call him I
called him eight times we're right here
your attorney we right here what are you
talking about where's the cop I don't
know he left oh dismissed [__]
tremendous old school don't leave me
hanging oh [__] dog I would never leave
you hanging dude I didn't know that dude
my bad I'm all in the Joey dude no you
have to and like um Heather McDonald her
sister was a big time DUI attorney in
town and she had rules like just rules
that you knew if you get pulled over
don't do this don't give me your blood
don't admit anything don't admit nothing
Lee you're [__] don't say nothing aren't
your friends I I I I I Joey Diaz gave me
a a star no you don't know nothing about
nothing you didn't don't admit to
anything you don't know no I don't give
a [__] what they tell you that a test is
coming with a mule I don't give a [__]
remember I had to ask you we were
driving home from Long Beach and cops
stopped like one row in front of us for
like 15 minutes and I had taken a video
view smoke on the way down to Long Beach
and I got paranoid and deleted the video
cuz I thought the cops were going to
come I was high as [__] I thought they
were going to come check my phone you
don't give nothing dude I get I get Arma
lawyers dude if you can't you know I uh
I do this Armenian benefit every year
for a I had a cousin who had bone marrow
cancer and you know she ended up being
it herself but the her mother's uh my
cousin Michelle incredibly smart woman
realized that there's no uh registry
firm Armenians cuz we're genetic
Hillbillies you know cuz we don't get
along with any Armenia doesn't get along
with they you know we're Christians
everyone around us are Muslims so
there's a lot of hillbilly [__] going on
if you understand it which made our our
genetic makeup a little [__] you know
redneck you know so it's like very hard
to find matches so they start this thing
well for like 12 years now I've been
doing this big event we've raise
shitloads of cash you know so I get in
some trouble I get b i I get bust buying
some [__] drugs from somewhere where
I shouldn't you know shit's going bad
dude I I call in who do I call who's on
the board gagos dude straight up gagos
and I call him up he's like Samuel I I
know who you are you help us with our
benefit how can I help you and I just
told him it's like boom he just sends
assassins dude and they were so badass
the cop who had bust me was crooked he
was crooked and they were asking for all
of his files and they sent down the
[__] the union Chief and they're like
dude nope we're suppressing all that and
we're uh dismissing the case and boom
who walks out my Armenian jumpsuit dog
[__] Like A Champion like a doctor
and [__] a good feeling when you beat
him at their own [__] dude cuz I was
[__] bricks I didn't want to get a
felony cuz I can't transfer that's why
you always got to get an attorney and
people don't get it because they'll
[__] rape you an attorney could just
twist a couple buttons maybe he knows
somebody down town maybe she went to
school with Paula and [__] USC we got
an in yeah have you been watching better
call all do you see the first two
episodes no it's not bad I watched the
first two Al on guard for me why the way
the first one was slow but yeah I don't
know second one was pretty good I'm not
in the mood I was really I was really
thinking it was going to suck before it
came out but I was happy with the well
there was all those rumors that it
wasn't I just thought it was going to be
a comedy and I just didn't understand it
but but it's the same guy it's Vince
Gilligan so it's kind of creepy and cool
and oh cuz what's his face was the lead
you thought it was going to be a comedy
yeah I just thought it was going to be
like a funny look at it I think that's
how they were first marketing it but I
was pretty happy with it no I didn't
know we'll see man we'll see they got
they it's always interesting when they
up they did it they did it the right way
they didn't [__] around you know Joey
spun off 18 years later these
[__] spun off the season later
they [__] around burn that's how to do
it you can bring those character every
character in the old show that everyone
loves you can bring them back in this
show and whoever hasn't died right well
no no no cuz it's pre it's pre-breaking
pre so everyone everyone's there but uh
it's kind of like what you were talking
about Bob Odenkirk is pretty well known
but he he just went in there for like a
smaller role and just killed it and
killed it until they had to spin off a
show you guys could do the same thing
when you're saying you don't have agents
to help you or like when you shot The
Longest Yard thing
with like
abused uh football helmet if you kill it
so much then they have no choice what's
weird about TV now is like one person
can have eight shows I've never seen
that before back in the day you had one
show now it's like you see people on
like four shows and I'm like when I got
here the one black guy from arless was
on two shows that's the first time I had
ever seen that I've never seen that [__]
he was on two shows he was on ABC and
the guy's back he's on a show on uh Nick
at night like kids show with the black
cheick tremendous you never disappear
you like dog [__] you just take a little
stay in the mix dog that's it if you're
good you're just stay in the [__]
shoot yourself it was a great listen
Breaking Bad was a great show you know
and uh I knew something they just did
everything right AMC you got to applaud
amcc they're doing some good shows and
they do it right they know what's
working you know Ray canelo's in town oh
he's back he's leaving tomorrow though
not he he came to do what we're doing
for Iron Dragon he's going to do for
Roku where he's going to do the
recommendations for horror films oh cool
so he came in I he called last night he
says he might go to the store later you
know same [__] I'm going to call when we
get the [__] out of here you know how we
do it though let me give some shout outs
real quick you got people all excited
it's a [__] Tuesday night can I do
can I also talk about my uh Valentine's
Day show after your show Absolutely
Ethan Buzzard Scotty chandelle Jeff
telman Goose Chris Boyce k Michael Matt
balazar Jean Smith and Joel pitzman you
got the [__] thing of the day you put
a Coke Rock and some chicks [__]
which I always [__] love you love it
love to do Coke out chicks [__] you
ever done that Lee nope would you ever
do it oh are you now a Coke guy I've
never tried it i' I've actually only
seen it a couple times where' you see it
at my friend's house that I used to work
on on TV show with he never did a little
bump with it he did a little lineup do
you like going fast you like going slow
I'm a fast guy I'd probably say slow to
be honest I'm more of a weed guy than
alcohol all right I'm a I'm a fast guy
so that's why I used to love that [__]
but now it's gotten so bad in La they
keep chopping it up I'm just doing chalk
at this
point Jesus it's it's early on I'm sober
early on Le we were talking about
corruption you know and if you've like
I'm
like I don't react to it no more react
to What like when I hear stupid [__] on
the news like if I'm watching CNN and
the governor or this or that I don't
react to it anymore like for example
like I know exactly what Al Sharpton
does he's an Insider right until
somebody says what do we need for you to
stop yelling tripley 500,000 they give
him the 500,000 he goes away you know I
know exactly what the characters do and
what their purpose is when you see them
pop up you you know what the purposes
right I came from Jersey I seen bad
politics for two years every time
Christie did a [__] thing he talked
about that guy sacko yeah now he's
getting indicted by the feds they're
looking at him the feds right you know
it's funny how he had this big thing
about he was going to do this and he was
going to do that but he wouldn't run for
president there's a reason why because
there a [__] they got you now with
the internet you can't do a [__]
thing and to be governor in New Jersey
you had to do something it's like Donald
Trump everybody oh Donald Trump Donald
Trump could do a lot politically but he
can't because he did a lot of shady [__]
right that that [__] comes up he did a
lot of shady [__] it's crazy that people
look at Donald Trump and go oh my God
Donald Trump put out people's lives he
killed people no but years ago in New
York with all the with all the [__]
[__] with all the construction in
the in the late 80s and stuff he was
shutting people's lights out man he
would uh subcontract work to guys that
would run up you know buy material from
them not pay the bill so these little
mom and pop Hardware stories were not a
[__] business there's a thousand
Trump stories if you read the Sammy the
buano book he does a whole chapter in
there about Construction in New York how
Construction in New York worked in the
80s and 90s and how they were doing it
and one of the stories he tells he goes
he breaks down how the whole thing works
and he goes okay let's just pretend
Trump but I'm not saying Trump who he
was talking about was Trump you know who
he was talking about that book was
[__] Trump you know Trump runs for
[__] president you don't think Sammy
the bull will be in that cell jumping up
and [__] down screaming oh he just
loves the attention I got stories you
know they're going to let him out
they're going to let him out when two
years a year they're gonna let Sammy the
bull out that's it he did his
time yeah he did his time so you you we
were talking earlier about the the mom
like are you worried that he's going to
go back and start doing SI again or is
he just so old I'm worried that he's I
give a [__] he's not going he's 60 years
old he's not going to why worry I don't
give a [__] about none of that [__] is
he going to go out who gives a [__] you
know they put him in there he's got no
[__] hair left you know he's he's
standing next to Cosby standing next to
[__] Su Knight standing next to the
UFC Karma served this [__] thing he
did so many steroids he got that disease
where you just shake not thek no
something else multiple sclerosis
something else that he lost all his
teeth he lost all his [__] hair oh no
you know you don't just kill 20 people
and get away with it you know and he
killed for [__] money I mean he would
do some horrific things but he did to
people who didn't pay attention he would
partner up with you and once the company
became a millionaire he shoot you and he
bury and he go out I saw him last night
what do you mean he didn't come home oh
my God we were eating bagels last night
for dinner you know he was cold blooded
he shot his own [__]
brother-in-law unbelievable he shot his
own brother hand the dog came into the
living room with the kid's hand because
they dug him up a few yards away the the
the family dog came in with the kid's
hand into the living room when they
buried him they buried the hand and [__]
that the dog found the the [__]
brother-in-law but what are you going to
do do you know I had those people around
me growing up whenever the evil evil
ones got close to me I felt them and I
just [__] disappeared I was very
lucky Lis Sayad I was very [__] lucky
I knew who those course were but I never
really I don't know like I said I just
didn't understand making $50,000 and I
had to give you $225,000 to be in your
club right do you ever wish that cuz we
talked about a little bit a couple weeks
ago do you ever wish that either uh not
not theaters but like barroom shows were
easier to do like it'd be there be a
better way to do it because how much how
some comedy clubs won't book you or how
they don't want to pay you they don't
they want to say how we go from Sammy
the bull to comedy clubs cuz you make
cuz you're giving them like so much of
the
money and you could just go to a bar and
sell your own show but there's issues
with bar shows you said and theaters you
have to rent it out and all that
stuff I just didn't understand the
Bridge over River chir there [__] sucker
I didn't get it I didn't even know what
the [__] you're saying because you threw
me off here okay I didn't know where
you're coming from we talked about that
it shows ago or last show but it doesn't
matter what's up with you Sammy what's
this Valentine show you Valentine's Day
Harv's two shows naughty show at this
awesome jazz club in Long Beach super
excited Saturday night Saturday night
all right for five look at you
Valentine's Day what's har that's Shan
in the eyes room I'm not sure I know
it's uh deep or that runs it yeah yeah
yeah yeah you're doing the room tonight
I'm I'm running over there after this
then I'm going uh this this uh this week
I'm going to do the host is showing the
eye he's got the one eye the glass eye
oh yeah yeah yeah sha ey Shan the eye
Shan the eye he's got the he's got the
one uh he's got one eye on you at all
times he's got he used to be a [__]
he used to be a bartender I met Sean
when he was a bartender in Arizona at a
[__] regular bar like 10 years before
comedy whatever the [__] it was you know
and now he's running a room in Long
Beach I heard it's a nice room great
dude you have a nice time now there I
always have fun and what's tonight
tonight's their weekly show yeah and s
you're doing two shows you're doing one
n 11 what's it seat down there I I think
you pack like anywhere from 150 200 250
standing and Long Beach is [__] sharp
and they get it D oh yeah this area is
nice dude really come along way and they
buy tickets to shows not like these
[__] in La who want to [__] get on
the can I get on the guest list it's
like $5 to show pay five bucks help the
talent make little cash remember brother
the guest list is something for people
to say they're on the guest list it's
not about the $5 they call somebody and
say hurry up contest my friend Sam put
me on the guest list you're on the guest
list oh my God how'd you get on the
guest list no I got you and they get all
[__] there's no guest list who gives
a [__] about a guest list I like when
they hit me up is there a code the code
is [__] suck my dick that's the code
if it fits in the Box go ahead do what
you do there's no code there's nothing
it's a 20 to get in what you want me to
tell you I don't [__] make the rules
it's not my [__] club
everybody's always look you know what's
a code I want to get on the guest list
what nothing bothers me more than people
thinks they think that something really
is out there like they really think
something is out there like oh my God I
went to Vegas and i s in this VIP
section you're sitting there going what
did you accomplish what the [__]
happened did some chick suck your your
[__] meat stick what happened no we
just talk to people who gives a [__] you
want to talk to people you go a chitchat
room in your house and talk to people
your pajamas on and [__] L yeah on
lincolin that [__] people trying to be
my friend on that [__] I don't want to
be nobody's [__] friend on nothing
people hit me on that new thing lincolon
to confuse me and [__] it's a
professional Network for professionals
all these out of work writers and actors
and [__] hi I want to be your friend on
Lincoln thing eras I just get rid of
everybody I don't even know what Lincoln
thing is I don't even know how I became
I get asked all the time I I never
joined I never joined nothing it's like
those Facebook groups when day I looked
down I was part of 18 organizations how
the [__] did this happen nobody asked me
one [__] nobody asked me one thing
that you want to be a part of I
[__] Anonymous I had to go
through all of them and erase myself
some kid hit me up three days later
why'd you get out of the group why cuz
maybe I don't want to [__] hang out
with you you know you want to hang I got
to hang out with you now on Facebook too
it's bad enough I see you at the Y
staring like a [__] Momo looking
around at [__] ugly chicks and [__]
[__] Momos there's a guy at the Y where
I go that he's a point of guy an xono
guy he's the creepiest guy in the world
he's about 60 and he C off t-shirt which
always drives me [__] I hate that
[__] if you got big arms put the [__]
take the sleeves off yeah but if you
don't have big arms put them the [__]
back on will you please going to walk
around like you know somebody I go to
this coffee shop there's a dude I know
he does porn cuz I I used to watch a lot
of porn don't really do it anymore but
used to watch a lot of it you don't
watch it no more no dude I'm just I I'm
over it but this guy I would always see
him in the [__] [__] films what's
the [__] was like eight like 20 dudes
one one chick like jerking off on their
faces and I was like where have I see
that guy and like oh damn that's the
[__]
guy you a big [__] guy Joey I don't
even know what [__] is I thought it
was like a cookie or something like that
[__] [__] what the [__] do I know
[__] I don't we learn something every
week dog I don't know about por you guys
know all about I'm [__] embarrassed
you not over it I'm over it you're still
addicted who the [__] are you kidding
you whack off all that [__] you people
are disgusting this [__] guy too
whacks off watching porn that's great he
watches Mexican porn and [__] when they
Mexican porn's good cuz they just kill
him at the end that's the way the all
should be they just shoot them for reals
and [__] they they shoot like the gun
they show the gun and they they show
like a a and they show like a body with
[__] blood splatter I'm good with
that unbelievable that's a that's how
you want to come see seeing your girl
get shot what come I come in a minute I
don't give a [__] who gets shot so you
just you just sit there and watch the
rest of the video no I've never seen it
I just heard that Mexican porn they
always shoot the [__] woman at the
end that's in real Mexico not this [__]
that you people watching now real
Mexican porn they shoot the [__] at the
end what it's all snuff huh for real
they shoot yeah [__] the [__] it's done
they shot aone puss I those [__]
snuff [__] that's uncomfortable do they
really make a lot of snuff films that's
I don't know but you always you never
seen the stuff film no I don't want to
see no [__] and
murdered that's my
favorite what's your favorite
one shoot me in the [__] when you're
finished that's that's the putting down
snatch oh my God that's disgusting yeah
right it's very I watched the Miami VI
on every morning at 6:00 and 7 on the
outr station and five I think it starts
from 5: to 8 so sometimes I got to wait
in the mornings I'm like I don't want to
[__] get on the computer let me just
sit here and write with a a free hand
and I put Miami Vice on it was a real
interesting one the other day about an
artist who had one he in fact the chick
was Jesus Christ today's Miami Vice had
Chris Cooper and the chick from Pretty
Woman the same [__] episode wow
what's her name Julie Roberts same
[__] episode Chris Cooper same
[__] he plays a dirty cop Julia
Robert plays the [__] kingpin's
girlfriend the one I'm talking about
which was the one I'm talking about oh
the one I'm talking Kelly Lynch plays
the model hotter than [__] 20year old
Kelly Lynch taller than [__] she plays
the
model oh [__] Al Pacino's girlfriend in
Caro's way plays the sister and the dude
from CSI Miami plays the artist like the
half a [__] artist unbelievable and they
[__] make a snuff film and then they
have to prove that the chick is still
alive so they get Kelly Lynch to play
the chick but the chick's sister shows
up and baffles the whole [__] police
investigation and says the sister hasn't
been home in [__]
weeks I can't wait till TV Guide could
just be that I could click on it I could
watch that 30 second video of you
describing the show rather than just the
the text Keep It Coming K sucker this
ain't no dream no more it's coming
together you know what I'm saying that's
how we make things happen at the [__]
church or what's happening now what else
you got going on how many weeks you got
on the road you going out you staying in
uh I'm not out as much as I want I was
cooking with gas but this last like
month and a half's been a little slow
but I'm I got a couple offers coming in
so we'll see what happens and you got
the punch drunk love doing punch drunk
with Ari shafir loving that and what's
the other one you got well I do a
naughty show but I'm just kind of
[__] feeling it out what I want to do
I did this I used to do the one that you
came on but it just Vicky wanted to do
her own thing and Gareth got really busy
so we just kind of said we'll take a
break and just hustling Bud trying to
sell sponsorship [__] getting
sponsorship for live shows that's what
I'm good at and just trying to stay
above water pitching shows trying to be
[__] Joey Diaz I'm no pitching no
shows do I'm at home minding my business
I don't give a [__] look at this poor
guy this [__] Cuban kid tested PO
today you know today you know I put that
video up of MMA junkie when we had him
on and we were talking about what went
wrong so so what happened are you do you
does your podcast whenever you talk with
with an MMA guy does go I see it on MMA
junkie what happens you they listen or
do you say hey we had blah blah blah we
had the host on we had the host on so
somebody cut made a YouTube clip and put
it on about what's going on with MMA and
all this stuff and then you know today
there's but it's funny I was talking to
a friend of mine this morning before
anything talking a friend of mine this
morning and he asked me if there was a
fight this weekend and I said yeah I
think Bens Benson Henderson is fighting
that kid scratch threat whatever his
name I can't say the name well there's
there's a bellor fight do you watch that
at all no no I'm talking about UFC and
he goes you know what I'll watch it well
he goes I'm not really feeling it no
more he because it's funny there's a kid
at work that said that's said he's done
with the pay-per-views for a while at
this last one it always seems when you
buy the pay-per-views it's a bad fight
or not inter and then he goes my other
budd's kind of you know and all a sudden
I I when I left this morning at 6:00 in
the morning there was already chitchat
from area hawani and Hector Lumbard
Hector Lumbard said he woke up to a text
from Mar helani telling him his fight
was off he got [__] he didn't find
out like from the USC he found out
online that his fight was off he didn't
know he woke up didn't know what if Roy
McDonald and then I left when I came
back in the afternoon that's when I seen
all the positive report that he had come
back positive unbelievable and this is
the last thing they [__] need now
when was the Rory fight anyway I don't
know
I think it was in going to be in May
maybe no April um but it's what we were
talking about it's how did uh Anderson
Silva still get to fight oh because and
then this and this guy got the fight
canceled well this the test came back
but it even took a long time it was
January [__] 3rd it's where they send
in these tests to I told
you
just to let you know tell that
[__] that sits tight it tested
positive then they tested twice they
break the piss in half they tested again
and you get the result two or [__]
three days later that's what I remember
in 1988 and ' 89 when I was taking P
test I think they've moved forward
correct everything in life has moved
forward we now have a phone with a
[__] camera on it walk
calar and I can tell where the [__] you
are well dude man this and this would be
the second pay-per-view in a row that
they let that happen they let Jon Jones
fight when they know he tested positive
for cocaine or not cocaine but whatever
you do to
digest doesn't matter cocaine
yeah when is that fight I'm uh I'm
trying to find which fight he's in the
next one cuz he he test the oh it's 186
okay uh
186 is April 25th oh yeah yeah in
Montreal where Roy McDonald's from that
sucks yeah that does suck man who's
going to fight maybe they'll put Diaz in
there they'll put uh they'll put uh
there's a couple people who could go in
there Tyrone Woodie could go in there MH
he just fought two weeks ago against
Kevin gastman couple people could go in
there they got plenty of time for that
yeah what's the name of the dude who
fought Nick Diaz and like was evading
him like the first dude to do Carlos KH
did is that the same wayos cond do is he
needs a fight and they want a match up
he's looking for a fight he's looking
for a fight and you know what he beat
him before yeah that's it that's the
fight Le sayak called it boom that'd be
fun MMA psychic cuz Carlos was on two
days ago to get really high Carlos was
on two days ago saying he was looking
for a [__] fight or whatnot so there
you have it listen it's just it's just
one of those things that the knocks keep
coming they thought that last year was
bad this year was open opening up not
good that card that Cardella and that's
the thing I've been saying since day one
it's the law of [__] diminishing
returns it got it moved too fast too
quickly a little too quickly and people
couldn't catch up you know they confused
some people you don't know if the fights
on Fox One Fox you know Facebook just
put it on one [__] thing just put on
one [__] thing fex you know where
it's coming from and dude there's no off
season that's the big problem like the
NFL this is our first week off and it's
you're like oh you're like you're
starting to Jones for it again you don't
get that with the UFC UFC is every month
all the time at least sometimes every
week they had they had some some weeks
where they had two fight two fights
going on at the same time in different
countries like one was Fight Pass and
one was they got to build a yeah they
got to say you got to you got to have
these Fighters like these certain
Fighters have to e they're only for
pay-per-views or the or they're on Fox
the you know the the the actual network
but you know it's like don't be sending
like uh Michael bisbing to do a fight in
China you know you know I want to see
him fight on a card on a real card he's
a good fight I don't need him fighting
in China watching him on the Internet
it's not [__] what you gota you know
you got to work smart but it's like
money money money money money money
money you can't do it like that dude got
to pick and choose because you can't
have just the problem is when you only
have one good fight on that card and
that fight goes down you're [__]
that's why they have to have Anderson
Silva fight when he when he's popped or
Jon Jones fight when he's popped cuz the
r card isn't strong enough to still get
you to buy that card I was just thinking
about it I've never had a good time when
I've bought the card I was thinking
about it cuz you're probably thinking is
this worth worth worth the 60 bucks I've
had good times at friends places where I
threw in 20 or or when I went to go get
like wings or something and watch it but
I was just thinking when I when I bought
the thing on my my cable I never had a
good time they want to throw up and I'm
a huge you UFC fan Dana White classic
guy are nice everybody's very nice you
just sit here and go who's making these
decisions to spread yourself out that th
now who's there watching this register
if you're having a fight in Las Vegas
who's in China watching the [__]
register you know I want somebody there
one of the fatias of me there right or
wrong Le what the [__] you were Jewish
somebody's got to be there yeah my
[__] like numbers like the Greeks
they always bring their mothers cuz the
mothers are the only people they [__]
trust they don't even trust a [__]
wife but my point being that it's just
too much and you're right it's just they
don't have enough pay-per-view Fighters
you have to have two or three great two
great fights and one fight that you're
like huh that's [__] interesting I
know him and I know him and I don't know
much about this sport but I know he's a
what's that [__] type people do oh they
fight oh and he's a jiujitsu guys so
they maybe they'll knock them to the
floor people know that people getting
educated remember Fox is to educate
people yeah Fox is supposed to be
educating people people who don't
wouldn't get to get a pay-per-view n out
of 10 [__] times you know that's what
fox is for they have to I they have to
Market Fighters they have to Market them
like this Conor McGregor thing is
obviously uh man of from Heaven I mean
his personality people want to watch him
fight but you know it's like there's
other guys that you just got to let
people know about them and get
interested in them the hype machine has
to Hype some of these guys so I know who
the [__] they are listen if I paid
somebody $50 million could I hype Sam
tripley right now with all the hype what
could the hype do for you you've been in
this town 15 [__] years next to me
yeah how many people do we know that
have paid
$5,000 hype doesn't do nothing okay it's
everything has to meet at once
everything has to meet at once we all
know Conor McGregor's great you know
what after that fight against Daniel
porier give me [__] what people want
give him the winner of whatever uh
Frankie Jose Aldo Aldo no we get Dennis
saver you're trying to catch him up in
the Jiu-Jitsu world and I get it but
don't throw it in my face this is all I
said last week you know what you me and
Leah
Comics we all get a deal in Montreal
we're all having a good time you know
deals whatever you may maybe you get a
half a mill maybe I get 300,000 maybe Le
gets 100,000 how would you feel if you
woke up and you so the President Fox and
Lee in Vegas waving out the [__]
thing you know yeah you know what I'm
saying so you have disgruntled people I
don't like when there's disgruntled
what's good for Lee is good for [__]
Sam triple I get you in an organization
so how can Conor McGregor go up in front
of Chad Mendes and go look at me I'm
staying at the fatita hotel in the
penthouse when you're staying in the
fighter hotel right there what's Frankie
Eder thinking what's Jose Aldo thinking
I stay at the MGM when I fight they put
you at the fatita hotel another picture
I saw him drinking a coconut with Dana
White I've never seen you know Frankie
Eder drinking a coconut or Jose Aldo
drinking a [__] coconut you know the
way he they let him talk to people and
I'm a [__] Conor McGregor fan he's a
great [__] fighter he's a great
fighter but I just thought it should
have been handled differently you know
it all started a lot with the cha sun
and thing when him talking to people
like that in Brazil you know hey man two
people do it out of [__] 80 that The
Killers what does that tell you if I
went around all day going you know oh
Sam tripley has to follow me tonight
[__] that [__] what do you think about
tonight Joey de [__] Sam tripley and
[__] the rest of the show my goal is to
go in there and [__] them up and so they
can't F what the [__] are you talking
about listen Sam is great I'm a great
fighter we'll see it whatever hype what
do you want to Hype I'm like I said
they've been hyping Sarah Silman since
we got to this town they've been pushing
Sarah Suman over the [__] border
since we got to this time she got 5
million Twitter
followers Gabriel sells more tickets to
[__] Sarah Silman I'm not putting
down Sarah Silman do you understand what
I'm trying to [__] say to you so for
20 for 15 years they've had this machine
behind Sarah Silman yeah and this fat
little Mexican dude selling more tickets
than anybody else in the [__] world
in the world and a [__]
Hindu you know how much push does does
the Hindu dud how much push does the
Hindu get how much push does the Hindu
get how many commercials have you seen
for Russ so [__] unbelievable right so
it's all word of mouth it's like Errol
Smith in 75 there was no Twitter I'm
back in the saddle there was no Twitter
you had to [__] rock it out there was
no Twitter so if you're good people
going to react to you if you have
something that's attainable people going
to react to you you know I love how many
people have we moved here how many
Comics have you seen that Zapped you
right up and we're going to be
Superstars they're gone brother
they're
gone they just just is it luck no it's
how you handle yourself you shoot your
load maybe you stuck your finger up her
ass first you kissed her neck you lasted
when I look in the mirror and I and I
know I'm in La 18 years I'm blown the
[__] away I'm not the best comic I'm not
even a great comic I'm a [__] comic I
just lasted here 18 years where
everybody came went no it sucks it's for
[__] okay this for [__] I'm going
to make a living here y I'm going to
make a living here I'm a [__] watch me
and I bet all these other people are
[__] [__] you can't push what you
you that's what people understand you
can't there's no really hype machine the
hype is you in that ring or you on that
stage yeah you're you're right but
they're trying to make the hype machine
with like CM Punk I was going I was was
going to ask John Lewis but I didn't
want to we had we're having such a cool
conversation it just if I tell you guys
something would you be mad at me no no I
don't even know who CM Punk is he's a
wrestler who's using from I don't know
where he's
from we yeah from that from WWE
apparently he was really good and they
[__] him and he left and I'm sure he's
a great athlete but this shows just how
much about money is because otherwise
why not put him in Bellator or King of
the cage or one of the other small ones
and just give him like a deal or
something because why have him right up
there Dana wants that that Brock Lesnar
publicity that Black Lesnar was the last
of the guys who could sell a million
pay-per-views nobody else can do that I
think Aron Silva Mighty gu GSP GSP those
three guys no no it was some oh uh
what's his name Tito no no the other
[__] guy
Tito CH was killing him for a while CH
killed him for
like CH did it too through hype but I'll
never forget you guys want to see
something interesting at home find the
find the Kane Vasquez Brock Lesnar fight
when Brock Lesnar loses watch the end
when when Dana White puts the belt
around C Vascar watch his face just not
excited it's not excited at all well
that's the whole thing about you don't
need to even be a psychic to know what
Dane is thinking I put so much money
into this big [__] lurchy [__] for
him to get beat by a [__] little
Mexican what the [__] is the world
coming to you could see it you could see
it I put Millions into this lurchy [__]
him not to get punched in the face him
to go down like this why do you think
Ronda fights so infrequently I mean
there was one point in which Ronda who
is a great fighter had more movie roles
than fights in the UFC because she's
such a cash cow that he he doesn't want
he you think he wants cyborg to come in
there I think he put as much makeup on
that chick as they want you know and I
like I like thick chicks but it's like
you can put as much makeup as you want
it's
Ronda is a cash cow he doesn't want her
to lose he loses Ronda Rousey it's like
it's going to be
hemorrhaging it's a bad situation Lee
look at the [__] shape you speaking
of round the Rousey she looks tremendous
on that Sports I love her I knocked the
bottom out of I saw it yeah I don't I
didn't know what with her and then there
was this fat model or something in there
pissed me off I don't understand there's
porn now the only time I ever got
excited about the Sports Illustrated
Swimsuit Edition was when I was 12 it's
it's uh symbolic that's why it's
traditional it's symbolic but the fact
that they put this fat chick in a bikini
it's like if I want fat chicks and
bikini I'll go on match.com I don't need
to see this F you know just like it's it
it it's she's cute though dude I bang
more fat chicks than anybody here it's
like this is meant for like it's like I
like playing basketball cuz I want to
play in the NBA doesn't mean I should be
in the NBA I can't dunk I can't [__]
shoot dude I love basketball but if you
put me in in the NBA it's going to ruin
that product you know what I'm saying
it's like Sports Illustrated whether you
like it or not it's still a competition
for who's who's the H chick in a
bikini a thick chick is K Upton she's a
thick chick but that's hot and sexy in
the big chick from salt and pepper in
the bikini that [__] will bang your
world dude all day every day jelly ass
and [__] bouncing stop it women don't
even want to see fat chicks yeah but a
big woman and a fat chick is something
different like there's something about a
big woman that's always like a bont
Tempo the chick who books The Improv
that's a big [__] chick when
she first came on the scene that was a
sexy [__] Aaron bontempo she had
only had the one kid then and she was
recently married you know who I'm
talking about yeah Aaron Bon Tempo rock
your [__] world she had some
big ass titties and a great smile that's
a big woman
I'm not saying she should be in sports
industry but I like to see her in
[__] bikini I do too there's some
women that are just big and sexy I'm not
talking about I like Viking [__] bro I
don't want a chick that looks like me
with rolls under a bikini that's
something completely [__] different
and that chick is attractive but is that
Sports Illustrated no no no you know
she's attractive I I see where you're
getting I'm coming from somewhere else I
see where you're coming from it's a
product and you can't just because you
want to play football no no but there
was something about it and I know that
we dig deep you and I take a ride to
Iowa and we'll see one of those 6'1
165s you'll look at them you'll look at
them and go oh my God that woman's
[__] beautiful look at that face on
first of all the prettiest faces God has
put on women are on those Vikings so
gods have to scratch their head guys
like what the [__] do I [__] what do I
do I let it throw out me out the window
they're [__] beautiful let's get the
[__] out of here Lisi I want to give a
shout out to my people over on it what
do you call it
optimization optimization that's the
[__] word optimization you want the
best that you could be that's what Alpha
Brain does that's what shroom Tech does
that's what [__] the the the the the
te whatever coconut oil does the
testosterone that they have oil the MCT
oil they don't [__] around they want you
to be the best you can be go to on it
right now right now don't [__] around
look at the minerals look at the
vitamins they have go to the box check
out something press in the Box what
church church CH h u ch and get 10% off
and they also have the stay on it
program it gets delivered right to your
house on a [__] monthly on the
first of the month stop [__] around
Iron Dragon TV you're sitting there
going Joey Friday night I I don't have
no plan Saturday I'm going to take the
wife off Valentine's Day I might take it
to Sam show I'm going to get my dick
sucked in between shows I'm going to
take it to a nice Benny Hana but Friday
I want to save money what do you got for
me Uncle Joey go to Iron Dragon TV what
do you put in the Box Joey Joey you get
two free classic Kung Fu films the it
man series listen there's too much to
even [__] [__] just do me a favor go
to irondragon tv.com do my do yourself a
favor this is a whole different F you
like the UFC you like people get mids
slapped classic Kung Fu is for you you
want to giggle from time to time cuz
you'll see strings and [__] you'll see
Godzilla fall from the [__] sky on
the wrong set of a kung fu movie [__]
like that happens go to Iron Dragon TV
right now Dave Foley's putting some
beautiful [__] together they got a
couple movies that a 4K technology
listen go to Iron Dragon TV right now
I'm pressing Joey boom get yourself two
free [__] movies you're sitting there
you sitting there you're uncomfortable
you ever been sitting there Sam you're
sitting there uncomfortable something's
not right you got to pick your underwear
out from between your [__] nut sack
and the and the Cocoon that lives under
your [__] they're wrinkling up when
you go to take a shower you take them
off and there's little Speckles there's
holes in your underwears but a lot of
people don't even know where to start a
lot of guys don't even know where to
start they go to get jeans they go like
[__] I forgot to get underwear you know
you forget to get underwear that's over
go to meundies.com right now they got
underwear for men and women they look
tight they're tight on you I'm going to
Jiu-Jitsu tomorrow I break out my
meundies why because the nut sack don't
pop out of the [__] underwear on top
of that if I sweat it contains it I
don't have leakage going down my leg
this nut swamp ass this swamp ass mix no
the material on the me on these pulls
are away from your skin to keep
everything fresh there's no shaing I'm
not scratching my ass on a plane none of
that stuff unless you want to unless I
want to which is a complete different
PTO when you got to scratch that finger
and sniff it go to meand these.com right
now look at the selection they have for
men and women I tell you what it's a
[__] bargain go to the box and press
in Joey 20% off your first order with
free [__] delivery to Canada
and the US that's how we We Roll here go
to meundies right now today tonight
don't [__] around Val if you order
tonight you'll get it by Valentine's Day
meundies.com press Joey boom you get 20%
off also this is the one I love the most
all right so I give you on it some
nights I give you a [__] ion Dragon
TV tonight I give you meundies this is
the best one I get for you cuz this one
is
absolutely
free f r e e free dumb [__] go
to naturebox.com you understand me
Health nutritious delicious snacks
nutritionalist approved stop going to
that [__] vending machine and getting
that old got [__] the cookies and the
[__] LIF Savers you don't need that
[__] in your life not when they got
[__] a nature box delivering directly
to your house not one bag not two bags
not three bags not four bags how many
bags leave five bags five [__] bags
delivered to your house for free and
you're sitting there waiting for [__]
the blueberry of Happiness he ain't
coming but Uncle Joey showing up with
some [__] nutrition and some [__]
snacks you understand me that's how I
make it happen do me the favor out of
respect go to Nature box.com get your
free [__] sampler pack it's [__]
free there's no strings attached there's
no credit card they send you three
medium bags and two big bags what they
pressing the boxey oh [__] Joe y boom
get yourself your free [__] sample
box who's better than you you got
underwear you got a kung fu movie and
you got pills to make you think right
all right that's all you get right now
don't forget I'll be at Cap City
Thursday Friday Saturday and at the end
of the month I'll be at Indianapolis at
crackers bringing down that [__]
it's been a long time last time I went
back to Indianapolis I smok crack there
with some black people that's my type of
[__] City I want to thank my man Sam
triple don't forget to go to his show
down in Long beats down there what's the
name of the club it's haral my friend
harvels that rames and Carell P show 911
where are the tickets Brown Bag go no go
to carvel.com carvel.com
car.com the [__] you Joe you're the best
dude don't be [__] I don't want to be
nobody's friend on Lincoln John no more
I don't know nothing about Professional
Network you want to be a professional
tell [__] Don colone to call me
[__] have a great weekend have a
great week Happy Valentine's Day you
[__] I love you [__]
stay
black Joey you were on fire
tonight a